Animals kill, on average,
more than 400 people in the
United States each year,
and the deadliest of them all
live a lot closer to you
then you might think.
This is where mountain lions roam.
They're considered one
of the most powerful
predators on the planet.
But they pose little threat to humans,
killing about one person
every five to 10 years.
They're far more likely to go after prey
like deer or raccoons.
But when it comes to killing,
size isn't everything.
There are more than 70 species
of scorpion across the US,
and together they kill
an average of one person
about every 2 1/2 years.
But none are more dangerous
than the Arizona bark scorpion,
which lives primarily in
Arizona and New Mexico.
It's one of 30 species worldwide
that produces venom
toxic enough to be fatal.
Next up is perhaps the most
notorious of killers: sharks.
Between 2007 and 2018,
there were 920 shark attacks
worldwide, and more than half
of them were in US waters.
But thankfully, most shark
attacks aren't fatal.
And, on average, sharks kill Americans
just once every 1.7 years.
And, actually, there's
another water-loving predator
that's more deadly.
These toothy reptiles range
from Texas to North Carolina
and kill about one person
every year and a half,
most famously a young boy
who was playing near a pond
at the Disney World hotel in 2016.
But even alligators and
crocodiles are not as deadly as...
bears.
In one color or another,
bears range from Alaska
down through much of the
forested United States.
They kill about one to two people a year.
And nearly half of all fatal
wild bear attacks since 1900
occurred in one of these
six national parks.
But even 1,700-pound bears
have nothing on spiders,
which, taken all together, kill
around seven people a year.
Most of these deaths are likely
linked to just two spiders:
the black widow and the brown recluse.
That's because they're the
only two spiders in the US
with venom that's toxic to humans.
You can find black
widows throughout the US,
and the brown recluse is native
to the Midwest and the South.
These spiders live in
basements, abandoned shoes,
and outside in piles of rocks and wood.
And you know what else you can find there?
Snakes.
The US has about 20
species of venomous snakes,
which live in every state except Alaska.
Copperheads are the
most likely to bite you
and live in the
southeastern United States.
But you should be most
aware of rattlesnakes,
like the eastern and western diamondback,
which are responsible for the
most snake-related deaths.
On average, snakes kill as
many as 10 to 15 people a year.
Oh, and if you really hate snakes,
here are the states with
the highest bite rates
that you'd definitely want to avoid.
Now, if there's anything
scarier than bears,
spiders and snakes, it's...
cows?
That's right.
Each year, cows kill about 20 people,
typically by kicking or trampling.
And about three-quarters
of those incidents
are reportedly deliberate attacks.
Of course, you can find cows everywhere,
and the same goes for the top
three animals on our list.
Dogs kill about 30 people a year,
most often from attacks that prove fatal,
and pit bulls are responsible
for more than half of them.
Bees and other stinging insects
kill nearly 100 people per year,
often by triggering an allergic reaction.
One kind, often called the killer bee,
is especially aggressive.
If disturbed, they'll swarm,
and can sting victims
more than 1,000 times.
And, last but not least,
at the top of our list
is an animal that isn't toxic
and doesn't generally attack humans.
Deer.
Each year, deer cause about
1.3 million car accidents,
and about 200 of them are fatal,
though your risk is much
higher in some states,
like West Virginia.
But taken all together, your odds of dying
from any kind of animal run-in are slim.
And when you compare that
to the leading causes
of death in America, you'll realize
that animals are the
least of your worries.